[Music]
[Applause]
the standalone game on sunday night is
chiefs and the ravens chris collinsworth
will be there with al michaels michelle
tafoya kickoff at 8 20 and the
festivities begin at 7 eastern on
football night america chris thanks for
joining us i know that you were at
florida spent your college days at
florida were you recruited by west coast
teams back then
i was i got recruited by usc and
flew out there
knowing there was no way i was
leaving florida at 18 years old and
flying and going to l.a but
somebody offers you a free trip to los
angeles you've never been before i've
never even been on an airplane
by the time i got my first recruiting
trip to florida state and i can remember
just sitting there staring out the
window like this is the most incredible
thing ever but
um
well here's my recruiting trip anthony
munoz took me to a lakers game
they gave him they gave him 200 bucks to
take me out on the town
he takes me to halftime the lakers game
goes ah this game's kind of boring let's
get out of here like oh okay we're gonna
go party in la all right let's go do
this drives me back to the hotel hands
me 20 bucks to get a cheeseburger and
says hey it's been a great time hope you
come here
takes the other 180 bucks and pockets of
sucker and goes home
but as part of the trip i got to watch
o.j simpson play tennis they took me to
his house i got to see the heisman
trophy i got to sit out in a little
chair and i think it was his agent's
house
while they played tennis and that was
that was a big part of my recruiting
show
we were talking about urban meyer you
know that that you can get a recruiting
class in college and it can change
you know your your program he he can't
really do that
and uh and i don't know if you can get
used to losing so it doesn't eat away at
you as much
but you know that whole college
experience of going from ohio state
where he lost seven regular season games
he might lose seven by thanksgiving what
advice would you give urban to sort of
ex not accept losing but somehow
tolerate losing for a little while so it
doesn't eat him up
you know it's a really good point that
you control the whole process when
you're in college football if you have
bad players it's your own fault right
you didn't go recruit the best players
that are out there
it's a humbling experience
you know either one way or the other i
in florida my junior year we switched
coaches
and we went 0-10-1
and
i'll never forget that experience as
long as i lived just because it was like
every time you went into one of these
big lecture halls that had four or five
hundred people in it and you would
and inevitably there would be some joke
made about the football team and i never
really experienced that you know in high
school we were always good we started
off pretty good at florida and we were
oh ten and one and i always thought that
alone i could win one game you know just
just one come on
surely i can make enough plays to win
one game in a season and it just was so
insane to go through that and for urban
i don't think he's ever had a losing
season in college i had him on a show
once and i looked i remember like i
think it's 17 years he's never had a
losing year and sitting on the sideline
the other day watching what was supposed
to be the worst team in football kind of
eat his bunch alive over there
i i don't think there's any way to get
used to that i don't and
i'm sure he was flattered and when some
of the usc rumors were starting to kick
around out there but i don't think
that's him either i you know i i think
he'll stay the course he's going to be
fine he's a good coach
but the other thing is you may not be
able to quite work
nfl players the way that you could just
sort of work
tim tebow in that crowd the only guy
that i really ever saw and get away with
that was jimmy johnson jimmy johnson
when he first went to dallas they said
those were among the hardest practices
in the history of the national football
league and of course when they went one
game i think their first year
and then after that it was day one
yeah i just don't know you can see every
loss
on urban's face
and they're not a lot of losses but it
just feels like you you
it's going to eat you up
like you know saban when he went to the
dolphins or spurrier when he went to
washington
you know they're like i don't i can't
control this i don't like this i'm going
back to college and i
i don't want to say that urban pulls the
rip cord after one year but
i don't see him coaching the entire
contract there because
i just don't i don't think it's in his
dna
well you know the other thing about
urban is he did walk away from it at one
point right and i'm not so sure if it
was him or his family or the the
pressure and and even in broadcasting
you know i mean i would i do the stuff
with pff now and i can remember when i
first started doing this if i had one
newspaper article from the san diego
times or whatever the newspaper is out
there that was like gold right i could
build a whole broadcast around that one
article because it was before the
internet you didn't have the information
now i couldn't i couldn't study all of
the stuff that is put in front of me
if i had a month to get ready for one of
these games so there's this frustrating
feeling of you're never finished you're
never ready you're never quite ready for
the game
and for somebody who's won as much as
urban as one
when he loses he
we already know that about his
personality he takes that on himself he
internalizes that so he's going to feel
like he's not doing enough for the
jacksonville jaguars to win football
games and you just worry about somebody
who has never lost i mean he has never
lost during the course of his career how
that will impact him because we did see
him walk away once he's chris
collinsworth nbc sunday night football
will be the ravens and the chiefs
i
was saying this early well on monday
that i could put together a highlight
reel of lamar jackson of all the
incredible things he did in that first
game but i could also put together uh
highlight reel of all the negative
things and it's only one game like there
was a like a brett favian type feel to
i i can keep us in the game and i can
keep you in the game
after watching you know the highlights
or the game footage uh what do you take
away from what lamar jackson is is
trying to do or needs to do
yeah it's not unfair and in particular
one thing you take away from almost all
his tape is
that when the game's really on the line
that read option is no longer an option
right he wants that ball in his hands
like they almost fumbled one because the
running back saw the reed just like he
did and knew that ball was his he saw
that guy just sitting there crashing
down inside but it didn't matter lamar
was going to take it on his hands
one of the things i'm going to talk
about during the broadcast
um is that that lamar i think when he
has more space to work with
uh is even better uh i think of russell
wilson russell wilson will drop 11 yards
deep in into the backfield
and when he
steps up that forces the angle of those
defensive linemen to be much deeper so
what was happening in the game the other
day
he would step up i mean he would only
take a yard or two drop after the
shotgun stab and he would be at about
seven yards maybe six yards and so those
ends of the raiders were just crashing
almost horizontally down on him and also
impacting him was the rush up the middle
but if he were to go a little bit more
which he did in this game some
to about a 10 or 11 yard depth and the
angles of those pass rushing ins becomes
much more vertical now they're 10 yards
deep with them when he steps up in
between that there's only two defensive
tackles in there there's not two
defensive tackles anywhere in the land
they're going to slow that kid down when
he starts stepping up into that space so
to me
if i were coaching him i would try to
create as much space around him which
would mean a much more vertical drop and
a deeper drop than what he's doing right
now what about an empty backfield why
not
put somebody else another lineman or
another wide receiver and just get rid
of the running back
they do some of that and and it's a
really good point and it is successful
and it does work
um the problem is they're playing 17
games now and as great as lamar is i
still think you want him picking spots
i still think that's why justin fields
is probably
really well served playing at least some
of this season behind andy dalton andy
dalton was playing aaron donald the
other night he knew he had to get that
ball out of his hands in two seconds his
average time to release against aaron
donald was 2.08 seconds now to give you
some perspective the fastest in the
league last year was ben roethlisberger
about 2.2
so he was he knew what he had to get
done but until you watch or play against
an aaron donald you don't understand how
fast that ball has to come out of your
hands and so i and i think in the same
way lamar
is a guy that that you want to be able
to control the rush and you want to be
able to control when you're running the
football you don't want to be just
taking off in 17 games a year and
running 10 12 times a a game
you're just not going to hold up and any
chance the ravens have to win a super
bowl obviously he's built around lamar
what did you take away from the rams
that you think is going to be
sustainable
man i i i really like matthew stafford i
i it dan i i went back and so
i didn't we don't do that many lions
games we just doubled over the course of
however many years now
and i said okay i'm gonna get ready for
this game and it was about a month
before the game i'm just going to watch
all matthew stafford's throws from last
year i just i've got to get a feel so
he's played in three playoff games he
hasn't won any they trade the world for
him they're going to get him so let me
just watch what he does
he is
really good
he is really good though just remember
at the end of this year i i came on this
show very early and said he's better
than i thought
and
the reason is a's got the big gun i mean
there's no doubt about it but he threw
some 45-yard
seam routes
after scrambling after the play broke
down and threw these rocket shots inside
of nfl starting free safeties in the
mobile field and it got there before
they did on his on those digs and those
crossing routes that are over the middle
watch him they didn't throw any other
night which i was really disappointed in
because i wanted to show it on
television but watch him
just maneuver with his eyes and he'll
he'll get a guy to take one step and
then he's so cocky with his arm he'll
throw that thing he'll whistle it and i
i can't tell you how many throws in a
row over the middle i saw that probably
missed the linebacker's hands by a foot
it's almost like he's teasing him like a
bull fighter or something and he's like
yeah you got that
and then olay you know and he's got him
and so it's really interesting to me
when those guys are at the high end of
that and we don't see it that often and
we didn't see it that often because the
team and in particular the defenses that
he had on those teams simply wasn't very
good are you in lyke or in love
i'm in life right now i'm in like you
know i still think that you love guys
with a proven track record of not just
getting to the playoffs but winning and
coming from behind and being able to
patrick mahomes is is a unique guy he
has proven now and he proved it again
the other day against cleveland that he
can take a really bad situation and go
over to the bench and go
guys come on i got this don't worry
about it you guys just go out there and
run around a little bit
i'll take care of us
and he does you know aaron rodgers tom
brady the great ones have a proven track
record that they do it not just in the
regular season but in the postseason and
and i i may love them but i i but i got
to see that
i know that people we love to overreact
that's why monday's called overreaction
monday but
is there a proper what's the proper
reaction to green bay's performance
against the saints
um one of those puking emojis or
something i i don't know
that was that was pretty ugly um
and i don't think it would have driven
any of us crazy
but for what happened this off season
you know i mean that was as unsettled
and off season as perhaps the city of
green bay has ever had
um and people choosing sides and people
oh let them go to denver we don't care
are you crazy you know
love's not ready for this you know it
just was back and forth and back and
forth
and last year we clearly saw
that ticked off aaron rodgers he did not
like the fact that they drafted jordan
love right he did not like that he came
into camp and he was mad and you know
aaron he's he's really good when he's
mad at the world and focused and locked
in
and this year they sort of went through
whatever they went through uh and
so even if they get beat on opening day
you go yeah big deal you know okay it's
gonna take a little while to get it
going but the fact that they got beat
like that
and they got beat by a saints team that
we weren't sure was going to be any good
and by jameis winston who threw five
touchdown passes on 20 throats on 20
throats he threw five touchdown passes
now you start to go
did this impact okay i'm 99 sure aaron
rodgers is going to be fine he's going
to bounce back he's going to play the
way he always says it's going to be fine
but did this somehow impact this
football team in a way
that is going to you know impact them as
we go through the season that's the part
i don't think any of us know yet
we we love these lists and you know with
a pro football focus or nfl network or
espn like you know greatest players of
all time
it feels like people have a problem
saying tom brady's greatest football
player of all time because he's not a
great athlete
like greatest resume
how do you
how do you you kind of defined that
greatest player of all time is it
the greatest athlete who is also great
at his job
like jim brown or lawrence taylor or
whoever you want to throw in there
but or is tom brady the greatest player
of all time um let me ask you this
question this is my legal training
coming back
you are a lawyer
well i'm not a lawyer but i i did
graduate so that that counts for
something okay was bait was babe ruth a
great athlete yes
he was yeah
so could tom brady be that same kind of
great athlete
so in other words i don't think i mean
to me
among the greatest athletes i have ever
seen in my lifetime is tiger woods
tiger woods
never gave up the lead
in a sport that is built to choke how
many times have you and i
played golf
and we've been through a thousand
situations we've broadcast super bowls
we've we've been at the free throw line
with the game on the line we've done
we've done all that stuff
and yet there's something about holding
a golf club that makes you choke
you just do it anybody would be lying if
they said they never choked on the golf
course and this guy for i don't know how
many tournaments in a row when he had to
leave never spit it up you never gave it
up so to me great athletes it's as much
about what you do in those moments with
everything on the line
and tom brady time after time after time
has just delivered on that and and now
you can't even say oh well it was the
patriots it was the great teams it was
belichick it was whatever
it was his ability
to
to bring that team together they all
talk about the text and the the messages
that he sent before that super bowl to
where they walked in that stadium and
they didn't think they were going to win
they knew they were going to win because
they had tom brady at the helm
so you would say brady's greatest
football player of all time
not even close
great to talk to you as always chris and
uh we'll be watching on sunday night my
best to the family thank you bud
all right man good seeing you that's
chris collins with nbc sunday night
football al michaels and michelle tafoya
interesting usc
uh answer they've gone over to oj's
house to watch him play tennis
oh boy
football night in america starts at uh 7
eastern
could i have been clumsier in asking the
question about tom brady greatest
football player of all time like a great
athlete and then where lawrence taylor
and jim brown and then uh god shut up
yes no i think you have to do the
semantics of the question because when
you say the greatest football player of
all time is it resume is it ability is
it um career yeah but he
i i should have just said
who's the greatest football player of
all time want to call him back
no he's probably still listening
sorry chris i
yeah he he just gave me a thumbs up
sorry about that took forever just spit
it out
spit it out damn